uh good afternoon everyone thank you for
coming um I will open the subcommittee
work session on House Bill
1387 relative to revisions to the State
Building
Code
um and um I guess I will recognize the
this yes thank you madam chair this is
actually not a vision to the State
Building Code it's a minor update to the
process for the building
code and
and at the hearing there were a number
of people strongly in favor the only
person who was opposed was a person from
the mechanical licensing board who
didn't understand section six which
merely added the words mechanical
licensing
um but that's still there that was there
um the reason for the deletions in
section 7
boilers that must have been 10 years ago
12 uh and that has
been instead of being a separate
statutory Clause it's in in the building
code and it's no longer necessary to
have a separate um separate statute so I
haven't heard anything that says we need
to make any amendments to
this thank you I I agree that we heard
from the
um president chair of the board I can't
remember thank you that um these issues
that were in the repeal have now been
incorporated into the codes and the
board felt that wasn't necessary to have
them cluttering up the laws
anymore uh does anyone else uh would
anyone else on the subcommittee like to
say
Sherman uh thank you Phil Sherman the
chair of the building code review board
uh we did have one minor amendment that
we would request on line
26 um we originally were suggesting to
delete the U requirement that the that
the model code be publ for two years
before we brought it Forward uh after
consultation with some other interested
parties we'd like to which seems to be
more uh it encompasses more fine details
and just takes more time to digest it
and go through it than some of the other
codes um gives them more time to
understand it in fact we can't move much
faster in the year anyway because by the
time we review it so we would suggest
that that two just be changed to a one
but leave the leave the wording the way
okay would you care to create that
Amendment yes the um the point is that
when it's a first issue the codes tend
to have some bugs and we'd much rather
have bigger richer States find the bugs
in the code than have us do it so I
might add uh the only reason we were
were fiddling with this at all
uh was to perhaps try and take some of
the edge off of municipalities who want
to adopt a later addition of the model
codes um but given the ratification
process that can only go so fast anyway
um so I I don't know whether that side
of things is is as critical as it might
be but
anyway if the if the Board review starts
a year after the code is published and
he really blame latent errors should
have been flushed out by that I would
hope okay yes I will get that
Amendment would the subcommittee be
agreeable to that small
change
yes thank you Mr Sherman is there anyone
1387 all right seeing none um I will ask
um I guess we'll take a vote just on
the amendment that we will be presenting
to the full committee um it's a simple
enough Amendment we can assume that that
I'll get it
correct all right I think I'll just note
that um the subcommittee was agreeable
to the
amendment and I will declare this closed
if you give me just a moment to make my
notes we'll get to the next bill which I
think will be
lengthier most
likely
for
that
whole
room
okay I'll open the subcommittee meeting
on House Bill
1059 um and this one actually is
and I don't see representative MC
Williams um I will recognize the sponsor
to speak
to whatever you care to speak to on the
bill okay the thank you madam chair the
update of the building code is something
that we do
regularly and and this bill as written
was what was recommended by the building
code review
board the decision on the energy code
was not unanimous and that's what
representative McWilliams had a an
amendment on that due to confusion I
thought I was presenting but was
actually she had it but in any event the
we should update the date of the board
meeting for ratification of amendments
which is on line nine right and 10
because some amendments were were
adopted in dece in January
actually um the question of
the energy code is the the only real
issue as far as I can tell there were
some minor questions that some people
had but for the most part the only issue
is the updated the energy
code
and uh that code
is significantly different from the
current code and it is
um well it reduces energy use it
increases the cost of
building uh commercial buildings and
houses es and it was there I think that
was why the the building code review
board rejected
it thank you so um I will entertain a
motion to adopt Amendment
0146 which is the one that just updates
the dates so that we can start with that
um is there anyone who had an objection
to just changing the dates that um this
would be ratified
right any discussion by other members of
the subcommittee no all those in favor I
adopted four to
nothing now we'll get down to the
nitty-gritty um we understand that the
the basic uh issues that we heard with
the bill were the adoption of the 2021
energy codes and I know there were many
people who spoke both in favor and
against um I do not have privy to the uh
Pink cards that we used at the hearing
but um I recognize several of the folks
here who spoke for and against uh I will
first re uh recognize Mr Sherman to
board thank you madam chairman and
members of the subcommittee are we
talking only about the amendment or are
point
yeah just quick question um there was a
second amendment that was supposedly
drafted do we have access to that
further
all that really did was change the
energy code date from 2018 to
yeah it's included includes the energy
codes in the bill Amendment
1055 uh
which is the basis of the contention
because the board actually did not vote
to adopt those am I correct with that
amendment we're not going to go into
taking public testimony again that we
already heard are
we no I I would say not I think um it's
not a bad idea though to just
articulated
y I'd like to suggest that we should
hear from the building cone review board
as to why they did not adopt the energy
code because I think that will influence
our
deliberations yes I I agree um however
like I said I think we should have at
least one person who was opposed um
to the
non-adoption
speak so Mr Sherman thank you uh so the
statement that the the vote was not
unanimous is true the vote was nine to4
uh which is not unanimous but it was
also not very close uh that came
subsequent to numerous subcommittee
meetings we had several of our members
um and unlike most of these committee
meetings it was the most open there was
a big table and everybody was sitting at
that table uh it was an informal
discussion and everybody was heard that
wanted to be heard many times uh so
working through that process through
numerous meetings and into the board
with a public hearing and then our you
know slightly more formal uh a hearing
on that um the decision was simply that
the arguments against updating the
energy code prevailed again with a vote
of nine to4 um it's hard to read the
crystal ball with 17 people voting there
were a few less than that at that
meeting as to why uh but the discussions
I think generally fell along the lines
of upfront cost versus what I'll call
societal benefits and payback
Downstream um and I think as you heard
the testimony and I'm getting my bills
confused here because some of the same
testimony was at multiple bills uh one
of the problems is that the money from
The Upfront cost does not go to the same
person or come from the same person that
the payback later comes from um so when
we look at things all from affordable
housing on up to Industrial and
University and every other kind of
building uh payback is fine but it's
only fine if you build a building so
there seems to be little dispute that
The Upfront cost increases there's 's
lots of dispute by how much um
everybody's got a study uh but I think
that was the General drift of the of the
discussions um I'm also aware that the
next jump we're going to the we're
looking at the 2021 codes today the 2024
energy code is held up at the national
level with a bunch of appeals but when
that comes out um my understanding is
that it will be a significant jump
um the word Net Zero is floating around
um and that has big connotations for
building construction so I believe and I
I really hesitate to put words in
somebody else's mouth but I believe that
there are those who are saying watch out
with this jump because the next jump
becomes even bigger um but that again is
my reading of a crystal ball that's a
cloudy what I would hope I just keep
repeating this so forgive me is that
both sides of this discussion remember
that for 20-some years now the state of
New Hampshire has created modified
improved a process to update the codes
um if we crash the process while
somebody holds out to get exactly what
they
want we don't get anywhere so there are
some benefits to new codes that don't
cost a lot of money in fact there are
some permissive things um but staying up
to date with some of this stuff is good
in and of itself just with technology
and other things so I would hope that
that somehow we find a way through this
without bogging everything down and we
don't get
anything so thank you thank you one of
the uh issues that I heard over and over
uh at the quite lengthy hearing on this
subject was um bringing the these codes
in for commercial rather than
residential and I'm wondering if there's
any way that um those two parts could be
separated uh in an amendment um what
would be your feeling on
that let me outline uh just in case
everybody's not um home reading these
codes every night uh the international
energy conservation code basically is
two codes Bound in a sing single book
there's one portion of that that applies
to uh residential buildings up to three
stories and the state of New Hampshire
through our amendments has expanded that
to all buildings up to three stories
offices shops whatever it may be um and
there's a square footage limit on that
so smaller buildings can be built to
those presumably relaxed residential
standards and then the other part of
that we refer to as the commercial SE
section just applies to everything else
so the larger stuff so think about it
with apartment buildings where at three
stories you're in this code and at four
stories you're in that code the
residential code the international
residential code which in an idealized
form is supposed to be a single place to
go for building a house one and two
family dwellings and most town houses
are built that way um has a chapter on
energy series of chapters on energy
which basically mirror the residential
portion of the commercial code as far as
I can tell they are word for word the
same um we have some amendments that get
that a little bit out of sync but the
principle is there so our proposal under
the base bill is that we delete that
chapter out of the residential code
because the residential code is going to
go to the 2021 Edition and that we
simply say go see the energy code which
would still be the 18
addition now if we slice the energy code
in half and we try and keep all the
residential stuff because three-story
Apartments probably covers a very large
fraction of apartment buildings if we
try and keep that all on 2018 and take
the
2021 um I suspect we would not want to
copy over all that ink in an amendment
which means people would then have to go
to two different books not the worst
thing in the world uh we do that with
electrical now we've taken that chapter
out of the residential code and make
them go look at the electrical code so
it's it's doable uh there might be some
groaning but I think it's doable um and
maybe that's what it takes to make this
know we we would ask for the opportunity
to put our our thinking caps on and
check the wording and see if we can get
it
correct one last thing I do have a
couple of comments on the base bill so
when you get back to that don't don't
forget me
please
y so when you talk about the difference
between residential and
Commercial and basically the cut off is
four stories or larger square footage
yeah so any affordable housing four
stories or more would be going with the
commercial code which would be much more
Pro I won't say would be possibility to
be more expensive to complete that
project would be
likely more expensive to complete the
part project 2018 to
representative McGuire yes thank you on
that topic I was told that many of the
subsidized affordable housing projects
are
um or have Federal requirements that
they go to the later energy code and I
which as the buyer and the Builder as as
the buyer of the building they have that
right even even if it were three
stories and
small I'll resist the temptation to
weigh in on that I I don't know the
that all right thank you very much um
and
I we had so many people um talking for
and against but um I felt that U Mr
beamus probably
expressed um the the folks that were
supporting of the energy codes more than
anyone else and I see him here and I'm
wondering if you would be willing to
opinions thank you for having me and
allowing me to testify uh Paul beus my
background is uh energy related
activities I'm a mechanical engineer
electrical engineer and also have been
involved with ashray I'm the chapter
president for granite state ashray
ashray is the organization that does the
research behind the codes so they're
upfront they lead with respect to the
science and understanding the impact of
these various
codes so the 2021 energy code focuses
primarily on a couple of different
issues um insulation being a big one
particularly ceiling insulation going to
a higher level of our value in the
ceiling also the walls and Vapor
Barrier so there's a number of reasons
why this is very important um and I'll
just start with Energy
Efficiency um you know a lot of the heat
we generate predominantly through fossil
fuels today goes out the chimney um
generally on an older system that tends
to be about 60% efficient so you're
losing 40 about 40% of the energy
for each dollar you spend on energy goes
right out the chimney fossil fuel
system uh we are moving towards
electrification through the use of heat
pumps a heat pump is a device that is
much more efficient than that for every
unit of energy you put into a heat pump
uh you get four uh times the amount of
heat moved by it it doesn't generate
heat it just moves it when you're cool
in side it brings heat from the outside
in and when you're hot inside it takes
heat and puts it back out they are
generally a factor of at least four
times as much as 12 times more
efficient however in order to make them
work effectively in our homes the homes
need to be well insulated and we need to
have a proper Vapor Barrier both are
addressed in the 2021 codes this gets to
an issue of human Comfort uh human
Comfort is something that can be
Quantified we know it when we feel it uh
relative humidity generally 40 to
60% below
40% uh human health begins to
degrade we get colds quicker uh this is
because our upper respiratory system
becomes more susceptible to Airborne
pathogens and because the Airborne
pathogens float because they're lighter
because they're drier due to the low
relative humidity this is true for
covid-19 it's true for RSV it's true for
the common cold so maintaining proper
relative humidity in a building is
extremely important to human health and
human Comfort that's the vapor barrier
Vapor Barrier is addressed it in the
2021 code similarly insulation is
important to keep a an even what is
called a thermal gradient and even
temperature in the room many of us in
our homes or apartments that we live in
know that there's a cold section near
the window or a cold section in the
house in the winter time and likewise
it's a hot one usually near the ceiling
in the winter time having proper
insulation allows you to maintain an
even thermal gradient throughout the
home so the temperature Remains the Same
and that is a human Comfort
issue so from an Energy Efficiency point
of view we're looking at the opportunity
to improve our Energy Efficiency in
these buildings by as I set a factor of
from anywhere from 4 to 8 using heat
pump kind of
Technology however to achieve the human
comfort factor you have to have proper
insulation and proper Vapor Barrier
these are both addressed in the 20121
codes it does cost a little more to do
this but you generally make up for that
quickly during the operation of the
building over its life cycle which we
hope to be in the range of 50 years uh
generally you make it back in a range of
four to five maybe six years depending
upon the
situation furthermore the value of the
home actually goes up a recent study by
um Fanny May showing 2.7 on average perc
value increase on the home for Energy
Efficiency that number is even greater
goes up to about 7% when comparing to an
older piece of building stock so new
home to new home one more efficient than
the other generally about 3% compared to
an older home upwards of 7% so the value
of the home increases with Energy
Efficiency as well well so we have human
health a positive in outcome we have
lower cost of energy we have of course
lower carbon contribution the building
sector alone which is generally referred
to as the built segment or the built
housing sector uh contributes to about
40% of emissions for carbon dioxide
worldwide a dominant percentage of that
is
heating um we use mostly fossil fuels
here in this region to heat our homes
very inefficient way to do it it's also
quite hazardous uh fossil fuel as you're
probably aware when it's not combusted
completely has the byproducts of carbon
monoxide so we have to vent it and that
means a hole in the roof in which heat
goes out heat that would be used to heat
your home furthermore fossil fuels
cannot cool your home it can only heat
it uh the benefit of a heat pump again
is we're getting off subject here thank
you yes I I agree I would um urge you to
I understand that you have a pretty
strong background in uh cost versus
returns and I think that would be more
important for you to address U those
differences between the 2018 energy
codes and the proposed 21 energy codes
if you could address that yes I
apologize I was just trying to give you
context uh 21 code is predominantly
insulation and Vapor Barrier extremely
important for transitioning away from
fossil fuel to electrification which is
uh what we have to do both in terms of
economics and in terms of carbon
emission the cost is not generally that
high
question thank you very much for joining
us today um are there any other
questions yes representative
McGuire yes thank you is there anything
in the 2018 code that prohibits the use
of heat pumps V vapor barriers or more
insulation than the
minimum uh technically there is not but
you won't have a a very comfortable
environment I mean you can put a heat
pump in uh many people are doing that
today but what they're finding is if the
build is not insulated to the level
described in the 2021 code by the proper
Vapor Barrier that it's not that
effective as it would be
otherwise any other y representative
goalie thank you madam
chair you talk about updating to 2021 as
an increased Health factor and better
for your health and whatnot my question
is at what point the make a house too
tight with today's synthetics and rugs
and furniture and everything else where
you don't get that air exchange and
being in a house that's too tight
because I've seen studies out there as
well that show that too tight of a house
causes
problems the way they address that is
through energy recovery ventilation it's
a device that you put in the home that
takes outside air and brings it in and
refreshes it with the indoor air uh so
there is no down side to having a home
too tight other that than the need to
refresh the Aira using a energy recovery
ventilator now um those are very
efficient as well but yes that's how you
do
it
followup does the exchange rate also
change is there how many how often is
the 2021 code going up requiring an air
exchange rate in SE building it's going
to three so it's going up to at 50
pascals of pressure uh it's a leakage of
three air changes per hour at 50
pascals little bit higher than than was
there in the 2018
code so a tighter house but fewer
exchanges tighter house don't confuse
them the air there's two two components
here it's important to understand the
difference the way we test a home is we
seal it put a blow door on it pressurize
it to 50 pascals and measure the amount
of air leaking out of it that's the
first one the second one is ventilation
how much air are you refreshing in the
building in order to improve the oxygen
content and reduce carbon dioxide and
improve the health of the occupants they
are different for air exchange rate you
want 3 to five that's generally what
you're looking for in terms of exchange
rate for pressure testing you want three
or less uh you want it to be low uh
passive house for example plus 6 so
those buildings are extremely tight the
2021 code isn't that tight it's uh
actually three under 50 pascals of
pressure so it's tighter than the 2018
code but
bit thank you very much for your input I
appreciate your attending thank you for
your
time
subcommittee okay seeing no motion to
adopt U the energy
Amendment um I will entertain a motion
to uh pass the bill with the amendment
that we have
adopted
move and do I have a
second
discussion all those in favor
I okay I declare the subcommittee
meeting closed
sorry